you
okay now this time we're gonna go with
the Sicilian h2 maybe I could play that
in five minute it's not all just cheap
Trick's Queen c7 it stays flexible and
okay so there's a bind here let's get my
Night Out pawn push you don't want to do
this I've done this in a I've done this
move as white when I was a Class B
player and over the board tournament and
then two moves later I was suffering
from the loss of a pawn queen a5 I had a
fight back to hold the draw actually
surprisingly
so don't do that let's see
let's do this I want to still keep this
diagonal open I still might have some
idea of doing some damage on this square
so I'm gonna do this move I want to get
my Bishop on b7 so maybe I can get these
two moves in very quickly also the right
B this might be time-sensitive such that
there's some lines where the bishop
could play to f3 and maybe it becomes
more difficult for me to get my bishop
on this diagonal quickly you know I
think I should follow through here get
my bishop where it belongs keep in mind
if Bishop g5 is played I'm not concerned
about doubled F pawns my opponent's
gonna give up their Bishop their move
the bishop that's more important of the
two the dark square bishop I'm fine with
that I have the bishop pair and a very
strong pawn mass in the center oh and I
also was threatening this pun I didn't
even I really see that I'm actually very
inclined to do this move right now I
think it's I think it's okay to do that
I think it's okay White's uh
one of the tricks behind this is that's
not an accurate term you use but one oh
one of the ideas behind this is to know
that White's play well almost always
involve having to advance this F pawn in
order to get some type of advantage I
have to do something with the F pawn or
the e pawn and this product could be
disruptive to these two and if either
one moves it's a very serious weakness
now what I had thought about is that if
f4 is played I could make this move pin
the night and then after Bishop here I
could play Knight g4 forcing Bishop
takes here
let's do that after Bishop III I'm gonna
go Knight G for Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes I at least get the H file or maybe
there's no rush with playing Knight g4
hmm oh wait wait wait wait
let me let me pile up on this night it's
another idea knight c6 yeah let me pile
up on this guy Knight takes Knight I'm
taking this bishop with check I'd be
winning a piece so I can't touch this
am I just reciting song lyrics now all
of a sudden you can't that wasn't
planned
night night c6 I meant you really can't
move this night so now I'm considering
this but maybe I still don't need to do
anything yeah I want to get this move in
what was that even doing though
let's throw my knight in in there right
now I want to make sure I get the H file
still can't move this night I get
something working on the H file can I
get my queen over here somehow it's not
so easy to transfer my queen maybe I'm
seeing an idea in that of queenside
castles and then doubling rooks what
would I do if Queen e2 is played and
this pawn is attacked why does something
to be I have to be a little cautious of
some stuff right after I capture a
couple times the rook here would be
unprotected which would allow Queen here
so this is being prepped oh I could do
this move trying to get at h2 I like
that move I'm gonna do it just like that
undermining this pawn the jeep on is
battling the F pawn if he flinches I get
to smash through on the Bill Gates
square so if before my plan is to take a
couple times on d4 and then I actually
went upon on f4 this Bishop is currently
overloaded right now there's two
defenders but he also has a job of
watching over on the night he has to
watch over that knight on d4 so there's
been a lot of time being spent like if
b4 eventually gets played only then will
I be capturing this is trying to keep my
opponent in this pin so now
oh you know what's gonna happen there's
gonna be a fork if I calculate this
correctly I think at the end of it I'm
seeing two rooks on f4 and d4 with this
move being a fork at the end but I
wonder how I should do this see if I
take here Bishop takes the bishops on my
rook if I take Bishop takes Bishop then
Queen takes and the Queen is on my rook
let me focus here for a second I'm
considering take on f4 I'm considering
take on d4 is there anything else these
are my two candidate moves so this pond
really isn't gonna go anywhere anyhow
pawn takes Bishop takes hitting my queen
if pawn push there's Knight d5 I really
don't want to touch this pawn eventually
queenside castle
yep queenside castle it is and now that
my rook is defended on h8 I'm ready to
do that combination of moves take here a
couple times take on that four I
wouldn't have to worry about some Queen
hitting my rook now there could be
Knight takes Knight here and oh what I
had planned was Bishop here but then
there's Knight check on e7 I missed that
I was blind to the I was actually
thinking that the knight couldn't move
and give check for some reason I was
seeing it making a capture on c5 not the
case here so here there's Knight check I
have to take like this and I don't
really want to do that now I need to
keep pressure on this diagonal so they
could get one of my pawns over here but
I'm gonna get the F pawn I miscalculated
we're even on time Bishop takes I
recaptured the pun I don't think I have
anything better so let me just pre move
that now they're slipping below less
than 30 Queen takes pawn takes pawn pawn
takes it's gonna be me can't touch that
pond
and well at the end of this I could have
some problems with my f-pawn but it's
not going to come down to that no time
less than five not happening how did it
their disconnection issue whoa must have
been some issue here waiting for server
response and that's it it's a forfeit on
time I think there might have been
something some issue right there down
towards the end my opponent was just
trying to type to me but nothing came
through okay not the not the greatest
way to finish but I let's let's go back
here let's see so had this open Sicilian
c4e for structure it's a flexible
flexible move it's rare that you can
make a Queen move this early but this
this opening it's it's justified because
it's a stable square she can't really be
harassed on b5 or d5 these knight hops
yeah my opponents now saying that
they're computer crashed
so that was unfortunate you know with 30
seconds left yeah that's about when you
started to chew on a ton of your time
there okay
Queen c7 see anything wrong with what
White's did this is the first move that
struck me as a bit awkward
yeah I wonder if there's something
better hmm yeah this is this is a little
bit awkward I mean you're defending here
see that but I wonder if there's a
better approach well here's another
thing you could always be thinking about
maybe this Knight d5 move it's not
really working you don't have your rook
on e1 I wonder if after Bishop e2
there's something is there something
better
hmm I don't know I know in the final
position it wasn't and have any great
advantage I mean you're building your
center while you're defending against d4
yes I have this knight hop I have the
h-file and keep in mind the other the
other idea I didn't point this out is
that if you're trying to stop knight g4
with h3 you're weakening g3 and so after
h4 that pond really clamps down on the
g2 h3 structure and the knight is ready
to jump into g3 so I think you have to
just deal with that keep these pawns
sitting like you did i reinforced d4 and
you're trying to get in b4 come over
here with your queen you're defending
everything and I wasn't really maybe
there is something better than I could
have but I'm still even you know just
right now I'm not seeing what I could
have done better I think at the end of
it after these exchanges yeah this is
where your your clock fell I mean we're
gonna have even material I really
wouldn't want to move this pawn because
that opens up this diagonal but I is
there something better for you like what
would be a good move here for you this
is this is the final position ah you
know I wonder if just after Queen takes
pawn pawn takes pawn there's something
like e 5 yeah I think that that would
work and it is opening up this diagonal
down yeah this bishop is a bug yeah it's
tough I guess that's one of the one of
the things that has to be weighed when
you are playing f4 when I do have my
bishop on this diagonal if f4 is played
he could be potentially having direct
side of g2 whereas if you just went a
single step you're really trying to
blunt the dog and I love the bishop
having f3 g2 but this is this is
sensible and that you would many times
like to get in a 5a space game move and
vacating e4 maybe jumping into the weak
squares well no this wasn't weak for a
great while but certainly the the d6
square is a soft point in the black
position so I'm not really sure what to
suggest for like how to how to maybe do
one better on the white side and I'm not
really seeing what I could have done
better was defended well I I know like
I've had a lot of players even in
5-minute games they they fall for these
these are these attacks on the H file
it's not so easy to parry but did well
to reinforce the the threats that I did
have not biting as soon as I played g5
that's for that's for sure but uh good
defense of the pressure that I had on
your pieces f4 and d4 but I don't know
that I'm missing anything I could have
done any better he defended well and
yeah not the not the greatest finish you
ended up having your computer crash but
I guess that's things we have to deal
with from time to time
alrighty good game as usual she taco
you